Matthew McConaughey you you know him
sure yeah you've worked with him and and
you do an impression of him I do do an
impression of Matthew I've known him for
years and uh he's a great guy and yeah
but I I don't I I don't really do
Impressions I just had this one
impression just because I hung out with
him a little bit right I just noticed
that he he doesn't have a shirt on a lot
of the time yes I'm not like one of
those rich little guys who can just turn
it on it kind of comes but then once
he's there he doesn't leave that's fine
first notice he never had his shirt on
right yeah and I I don't know I just and
I used to hang out with them when we
were you know broke actors and and uh so
I don't I don't I don't know man I you
know but what I would say was I would go
in to the morning you know every morning
on the set of Oceans 13 and to Steven
Soderberg and I'd say um
uh Mr Soderbergh
today's scene I think would be a good
opportunity for me to take my shirt off
laughs